Hey David, is it fair not to let yang and
Tulsi speak during the debates?
It's not, I've, I've talked about this, we
did a big piece about this on the Monday show
where I explained, I think there are too many
people on the stage.
I think there should be five, maybe six at
this point at the most based on who still
has a shot and how far into this thing we
are, but if you make the stage you should
get roughly equal time.
I don't agree with the network making editorial
decisions to say if you're pulling better
you will get more time.
If you're pulling poorly you'll get less time
except where we want to do it differently.
And what we saw in the fifth MSNBC, the fifth
debate which was on MSNBC last week was that
for example, Andrew Yang got drastically less
time than his polling support would predict.
On the other hand, Pete booted.
Judge was the biggest beneficiary who got
significantly more time on screen talk time
then his polling would suggest.
So I do not think it's fair for yang and Tulsi
to speak during the, I'm no fan of Tulsa's
and she has no shot, but if she makes the
debate she should get the same amount of time
as everybody else.
Andrew Yang I like, I don't think he's going
to be the nominee.
I've interviewed him on the program perfectly.
Nice guy.
Has good ideas.
He should get the same amount of time as everybody
else.
If he has made the debate, if your argument
is these people don't really have a shot at
winning, so it makes sense not to give them
much time, well then they shouldn't be on
the stage.
If that's your, uh, your, the DNC is running
the election, they should have requirements
for making the debate stages that make sense.
They should not be leaving it up to the whims
of for-profit media who may have all sorts
of different priorities themselves.
MSNBC 10 trending towards the sort of more
establishment centrist Democrats like Joe
Biden, uh, Pete, Buddha, judge, they seem
to sort of have reluctantly made the call
that if it is going to be a more progressive
candidate that wins between Warren and Bernie.
They prefer Warren's or they've been talking
up Warren over, over Bernie and they've been
particularly unfair to Andrew Yang referring
to him as John Yang at least once, if not
more.
They put a poll up on the screen a couple
of weeks ago where they just ignored the Andrew
Angus wasn't on the screen even though he
was pulling, I think in that poll 3% they
had people on screen who were polling to just
no explanation why John Yang or as he's actually
called Andrew Yang wasn't there.
So I want to be really clear.
This is not me being a yang ganger or anything.
I've said I'm a, I'm a Bernie Warren guy,
but fair is fair.
And if you make the stage, you should get
the time that everybody else gets.
It should be evenly distributed.
If in a poll, you're in sixth place, you shouldn't
show one through five, skip person number
six and then seven, eight, nine, whatever.
You should just put the person up there.
That's it.
It's just not fair.
And it's bizarre and it's strange.
And to your question, it's not fair to let
Andrew Yang and Tulsi, uh, uh, uh, speak so
little when they have made the debate stage
based on the requirements that have been put
in place by the DNC.
We've got a great bonus feel for you today,
where I will be facing off against producer
Pat Ford in a pre Thanksgiving chess match.
What will happen?
There's only one way to find out, and that
is to check out the video version of today's
bonus show.
Become a member@joinpacman.com or become a
[inaudible]
patron at patrion.com/david Pakman show to
get instant access to the bonus show and through
today's chess match, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].